[Music]
i want to start by saying i know you're
from uh and you live in the new york
area yes i do and uh you guys just went
uh through this terrible storm
i'm reading reports that people it was
very difficult for people to vote did
you vote yeah you know the whole thing
with the voting now is that uh because
of this you know uh sandy yeah of course
uh the hurricane sandy they kept moving
locations so like it became kind of like
this flash mob thing like it's like okay
go down the block okay you're gonna see
a dude go up an elevator all right i'm
in a dude's apartment i don't even know
if i voted
or did his laundry i'm not exactly sure
what i did but
that's why i like when they canceled the
marathon i was a little depressed and
you know i know a lot of people like we
shouldn't have a marathon i'm like we
should yeah you know because like first
of all we got all these people they're
amazing athletes we should hook them up
to treadmills and let them power the
city i think that'd be great
come on dude keep it moving
5k i got an xbox i want to play
that's a fantastic idea well how did you
personally cope with the storm how did
you deal with it well uh it's pretty
difficult because uh you know batteries
became like money and i'm not even going
to tell you about gas gas is like wow
but batteries were like money and uh i'm
lucky because i prepped you know i'm a
prepper so i got this flashlight and you
wind it up for like an hour and a half
you know just keep winding it and it
gives you like 30 seconds of light it's
amazing
just enough to see like a guy breaking
your apartment